[Applaudissements]
chers jeunes chères
homo sapiens de mon espèce je
m'attendais pas à vous voir aussi
impressionnant en face de moi ce soir
je voudrais vous inviter à réfléchir
avec moi ce qui nous distingue des
autres espèces animales mais bien ce qui
nous différencie
eh bien ce n'est pas tellement la
biologie finalement c'est plutôt
l'immense capacité qu'a su développer
l'être humain pour développer des objets
artificiels des outils dont il se sert
pour vivre et ainsi au cours de son
évolution
homo sapiens nous nous sommes plutôt
devenir devenu homo faber
nous fabriquons messi voulant si nous
voulons découvrir qui est réellement
homo sapiens qui nous sommes il est
intéressant de regarder finalement
qu'est ce que nous fabriquons est ce que
nous fabriquons des grandes choses est
ce que nous fabriquons des petites
choses ou est ce que finalement nous
fabriquons des choses dérisoires
alors évidemment homo sapiens qui
développe ses premiers outils les faits
son échelle il est émerveillé par les
outils qu'il construit qui l'aide à
vivre à progresser et il se dote ainsi
d'un pouvoir assez fascinant et pour
symboliser la puissance des outils qui
s'est dotée il a tendance à fabriquer
des objets très gros son jour par
exemple aux pyramides d'égypte ces
grandes fabrication qui en fait sont
solides forte pointu qui montre
réellement la puissance par la grandeur
plus près de nous par exemple si l'on
songe à cette vieille dame d'acier qui a
été érigé dans l'ère moderne justement
pour montrer à quel point homo sapiens
était fier de sa nouvelle ingénierie
évidemment depuis 50 ans maintenant des
objets que fabrique l'humain ont pris
des aspects très différents
ou plus exactement des tailles très
différentes
depuis 50 ans il s'est mis en tête de
conquérir la toux petite échelle et il
s'est doté d'une fantastique boîte à
outils qu'on appelle des nôtres
vie qui lui permettent de miniaturiser
ses objets ses artefacts à une échelle
qui est celle du milliardième de mètre
dans mon laboratoire par exemple avec un
magnifique outil issu de cette boîte à
outils des nanotechnologies nous avons
fait exactement un de mes étudiants à
fabriquer une tour eiffel assez
similaire à celle ci sauf qu'évidemment
sa hauteur au lieu d'être de 300 mètres
et de 300 microns évidemment pour
fabriquer la vraie tour eiffel il a
fallu à peu près 5 millions d'heures de
travail humain alors que mon étudiant à
la réaliser en une heure évidemment si
l'on regarde aussi le poids de la tour
eiffel 10 millions de kg contre 3
milliardième de milliardième de
kilogrammes pour celles qui la fabrique
et on voit bien la frénésie des échelles
et la totale différence entre ces objets
là autant pour vous il est clair de
comprendre à quoi sert une tour eiffel a
montré à tous les parisiens qui lève la
tête qui voit cette immense tour combien
puissante et l'ingénierie et
l'ingéniosité de l'esprit humain
autant on peut s'interroger à quoi sert
cette toute petite tour eiffel puisque
pour vous la montre est évidemment j'ai
dû prendre une photo avec vous au
microscope électronique et comme chacun
sait tous les homos sapiens non pas ça
chez eux le soir pour s'amuser à ça et
donc en fait je vous invite à un voyage
pour découvrir pourquoi en faisant petit
finalement eh bien il ya aussi une part
de puissance un peu démiurgique dans
cette activité d' homo sapiens en effet
si on essaie de répondre à cette
question pourquoi quand on fait des
choses si petit on va dire un anneau et
bien pourquoi finalement on arrive à une
très grande efficacité ou à une très
grande puissance des objets qu'on a
fabriqué en fait le seul résumé de tout
ça c'est que plus on fait petit et plus
les effets sont multipliés c'est à dire
qu'en divisant les dimensions on
multiplie les effets c'est presque une
parabole évangélique de la division qui
augmente les effets évidemment on
multiplie par 2 ou par 3 puisque on
divise par un milliard on multiplie ses
également parrain milliards alors
évidemment on peut s'interroger aux
raisons scientifiques qui font qu'en
faisant petit finalement on fait des
objets très puissant ou très efficace
j'envoie 5
je vais si les énumérer avec vous très
rapidement la première c'est que quand
on fait des objets petit on peut faire
plein un meilleur exemple de ça c'est de
regarder nos processeurs qui sont en
tout dans tous les dispositifs
électroniques qui nous entourent et qui
façonnent notre vie et notre
comportement social aujourd'hui dans un
processeur commercial aujourd'hui c'est
à peu près 1 centimètre carré de
silicium on trouve environ 10 milliards
de transition électronique et c'est
parce qu'ils sont aussi nombreux qu'ils
ont une telle puissance qui vont si vite
qu'ils nous permettent de communiquer à
haut débit c'est eux qui sont au coeur
de l'internet qui sont au coeur de des
réseaux télécommunications ils sont
aussi au coeur de l'intelligence
artificielle parce que c'est en faisant
ces circuits aussi compliquée avec tant
de composants qu'on arrive à traiter si
rapidement autant d'informations et
qu'on peut faire ses calculs
ainsi ces dispositifs les nanos sont à
l'origine de ce que j'appelle moi
l'électronique fication de notre
environnement
cette idée de faire des machines qui
vont communiquer entre elles qui vont
avoir de la mémoire qui vont traiter
l'information et qui vont coexister avec
homo sapiens très intéressant si vous
regardez le prix d'un processeur
aujourd'hui 100 euros environ
et si vous dites dans ce processeur g 10
milliards de transistors
je me suis amusé à calculer quel est le
prix d'un transistor eh bien on trouve
dinan euros ne cherchez pas ces pièces
dans votre porte-monnaie elles sont
invisibles comme tout les nano mais tout
ça pour dire qu'on est capable de faire
ça évidemment un coût qui fait qu'on
peut se l'acheter et donc en fait parce
qu'elles sont petites
on peut mettre ces dispositifs y sont
pas gros dans la proche et parce que
finalement on les produit un coût très
faible
tout le monde peut s'en équiper et c'est
une grande leçon des nano par leur
diffusion dans la société elles vont
fortement impacté sur la façon dont on
va se comporter le deuxième effet est
aussi très simple à comprendre
lorsque vous regardez un bloc massif
comme ce bloc de gauche et bien tous les
atomes sont à l'intérieur de la matière
très peu sont en surface et pour un
gramme de matière
surface a déployé par cet objet sont de
l'ordre du centimètre carré une pièce de
monnaie
si maintenant au lieu d'avoir ce blog
vous le dis fils dit viser un tout petit
particules jusqu'à l'échelle
nanométrique
et bien pour la même quantité de manière
un gramme vous allez avoir une surface
qui est équivalente à celle d'un terrain
de rugby
alors pourquoi faire autant de surface
avec si peu de matière parce que tous
les échanges d'un matériau avec son
environnement ont lieu à la surface les
échanges thermiques les échanges
d'énergie
si vous voulez récupérer de l'énergie
grappillé si vous voulez catalyser les
réactions chimiques tout ça se passe en
surface
si votre matériaux n'est que surface
vous allez multiplier les effets
catalytique vous pouvez dépolluer des
sols vous pouvez aussi faire des
électrodes pour des batteries qui vont
avoir d'immenses propriétés et ainsi en
coupant petit et bien on multiplie les
effets l'efficacité de tous ses produits
le troisième effet dont je voudrais vous
parler maintenant c'est que quand on
fait des objets petits sont différents
des objets gros et ça c'est la physique
quantique qui nous enseigne la propriété
d'un matériau on a longtemps cru qu'elle
dépendrait de la nature des atomes qui
le constituent et puis on a découvert au
xxème siècle que ça dépendait aussi de
la structure entre les atomes mais on a
découvert avec les nanotechnologies que
ça dépendait aussi de la taille des
objets qu'on va fabriquer et cet effet
quantique nous permet d'imaginer des
choses fantastiques on peut créer des
matériaux qui vont avoir une propriété
particulière
justin ajustant leurs dimensions
l'exemple le plus fou et le nanotube de
carbone il cumule tout ce qu'on a dit
jusqu'à présent tous les atomes sont des
atomes de carbone
cette structure de cylindrée qui fait un
diamètre d'environ excusez-moi de
nanomètres où tous les atomes sont en
surface donc là aussi il y aura une très
grande réactivité et bien en changeant
le diamètre de sa main
youtube de quelques nanomètres je peux
le rendre extrêmement conducteur je peux
le rendre semi conducteurs ou je le peux
le rendre isolant ce matériau a des
propriétés de résistance mécanique qui
sont 10 fois supérieure à la sienne pour
un poids qui a environ six fois plus
léger donc on voit que par les nanos en
contrôlant la taille des matériaux qu'on
fabrique ont fait émerger des propriétés
tout à fait nouvelle qui nous permettent
d'avoir une ingénierie qui ne se base
pas que sur des matériaux naturels mais
sur des matériaux fabriqués
intentionnellement avec une dimension
choisi la 4e effet très simple à
comprendre c'est que quand vous faites
un objet si petit si nanométrique
il peut se faufiler partout et en
particulier si vous voulez mettez à
l'intérieur d'un organisme vivant
il va pouvoir s'infiltrer dans toutes
les barrières biologiques est passé à
travers les cellules rentrer dedans et
donc aussi les gens on imaginait
utiliser ces petits nano objets pour
amener des drogues des molécules
médicamenteuses uniquement vers les
cibles qu'elles peuvent atteindre ainsi
un objet creux d'un homme et riz qu'on
va appeler un vecteur de médicaments qui
est chargé avec une molécules
médicamenteuses va être capable de
suivre son parcours dans un corps humain
par exemple et finalement se
concentraient à l'endroit par exemple où
il existe des tumeurs où il va pouvoir
relarguer le médicament qui est à
l'intérieur plusieurs centaines de nano
vecteur de médicaments en oncologie sont
à l'heure actuelle un essai clinique
voir utilisées dans certaines
pathologies
donc ça ouvre d'immenses espoirs de ce
côté là
la dernière idée qui est très simple
mais quand même plus compliqué à
comprendre c'est que les cellules elles
mêmes les cellules vivantes parle le
langage et nanotechnologies tout ce
qu'on va trouver à l'intérieur d'une
cellule tous ces nano moteurs tous ses
pores et ionique sur les membranes
toutes les fibres qui constitue le
cytosquelette des cellules est à
l'échelle nano quand le tenait des
technologues aussi fabrique des
nanostructures sur une surface
et bien c'est nanostructures ont la
bonne échelle pour interagir directement
avec les cellules vivantes avec les
composantes d'un autre cellule
en t on à découvert au cours des
dernières années comment en structurant
à l'échelle nanométrique une surface on
peut expliquer à des cellules comment
elles doivent se comporter ou est-ce
qu'elles doivent adhérer ou est-ce
qu'elles doivent pousser avec qui elles
doivent se connecter et ainsi par
exemple sur cette image à gauche sur la
surface nous avons fait des choses qui
explique à ses neurones humains de se
mettre en ligne bien droite au milieu on
a mis autre chose une autre indice
nanométrique pour dire allez-y
branchez-vous latéralement et sur la
partie droite on a expliqué à ses
neurones convenablement qu'on voulait
qui s'appelle ça paris deux par deux
c'est juste un exemple pour vous montrer
que par les nano on peut prendre le la
main sur le comportement des cellules
vivantes
ainsi pour beaucoup ça ouvre de
fascinant espoir pour essayer par
exemple à partir de cellules
progénitrices vivante de reconstituer
des tissus fonctionnel voir des organes
fonctionnels qu'on pourrait réimplanter
évidemment pour soigner des nécroses ou
d où d handicap profond qui sont acquis
donc pour la médecine évidemment cette
faculté que par les nano on peut
interagir directement avec les cellules
vivantes offre homo sapiens une très
grande puissance de feu ces deux
dernières idées qu'on peut se faufiler
partout et que par les nano on peut
expliquer à des cellules vivantes
comment elles doivent se comporter qui
aujourd'hui moi dans ma recherche me
fascine le plus et je trouve que ça
active des vieux rêves ou des vieux
fantasme qui ont été beaucoup repris par
l'industrie cinématographique
vous avez une image d'un film de ma
génération qui s'appelait le voyage
fantastique c'est un film américain il
avait imaginé quand vous pouvez
miniaturisés des petits vaisseaux comme
ça mais aussi des petits bonhommes et
c'est un film où on voit quelques cet
objet avec ces êtres qui qui rentre dans
le corps humain
donc en fait comme ça se faufile partout
par les nano on a une façon avait
effectivement peut-être d'aller vers ce
délire où ce fantasme de rentrer dans le
corps et d'ivoire et d'agir le second
est un film plus récents qui s'appelle
les repreneurs
on est dans une société américaine
gouverné par les lois économiques et le
libéralisme est une société vous le
voyez sur étagère fait ces fameuses
organes par les nano est capable de
faire des organes de réparation il ya
une société qui les vend évidemment les
deux méchants que vous voyez au centre
sont chargés quand la personne qui a
reçu un organe tout neufs ne paie pas la
note d'aller lui reprendre et l'arraché
et ça donne évidemment un futur assez
sombre à ce genre de pratique dans ma
recherche gc très humblement d'aller
dans cette direction là je vais vous
montrer mon premier voyage fantastique
c'est celui-là avec plein de
collaborateurs dont j'ai pas ici le
temps de vanter les mérites et
l'ingéniosité nous concevons finalement
ce vaisseau il est tellement petit qu'on
va pouvoir leur entrée à l'intérieur
d'une vaine au bout d'un cathéter
il va avoir pour mission finalement de
filtrer toutes les cellules circulantes
et de ne retenir en son sein que des
cellules cancéreuses qui circulent dans
le sang humain lorsque un patient est
atteint d'une tumeur en voie de
prolifération est ainsi par ce biais là
on peut faire une biopsie de la tumeur
simplement en posant un cathéter dans
une veine sans avoir à opérer un patient
on peut faire du diagnostic précoce on
peut faire du dépistage
on peut faire aussi du suivi de
l'efficacité des thérapies voir
effectivement adapter la thérapie pour
chaque patient en fonction de la
spécificité de la biologie de son cancer
vous voyez qu'on est quand même loin des
petits bonhommes qui pilote le vaisseau
et qui rentre dans le corps humain mais
on est quand même drivée par cette idée
que en faisant petit finalement on peut
rentrer en soi et commencé à faire des
choses et à réparer la deuxième chose
que je voudrais vous dire qui est plutôt
sur la partie jeu et essayer de réparer
des organes sur l'image de gauche c'est
des choses qu'on fait en trois
dimensions voyez là on utilise la même
technique qui a permet par exemple de
faire la tour eiffel mais on essaie de
faire un objet qui va expliquer à des
neurones humain à partir de cellules
souches de refaire un tissu qui
ressemble au tissu cérébral qui est lésé
chez des patients qui sont atteintes
d'un avc d'un accident vasculaire
cérébral qui les rend handicapés pour
très longtemps on est encore très loin
de savoir comment fabriquer un objet par
les nanos et le fer avec les bons
indices topographiques biochimiques
mécanique pour qu'effectivement les
cellules souches qu'on va mettre dedans
reforme un tissu cérébral fonctionnel
mais l'on progresse j'en viens
maintenant une partie plus délicate de
mon exposé c'est que ça c'est ce que je
fais c'est ce que je crois et c'est ce
que je défends mais sur la même idée on
trouve plein de choses et j'ai des
collègues malheureusement ça me peine à
le dire qu'ils sont chercheurs qui
comprennent ces technologies aussi bien
que moi qui perdent un peu la boule et
qui disent par exemple
bon je vais pas faire de la culture
cellulaire et d'essayer d'expliquer
aussi lu ce qu'elles doivent faire
je vais carrément aller dira je vais
faire un organe sur une puce et puis
quand ils vont plus loin s'ils font
pousser des cellules comme ça qui
commence à ressembler à des organes et
qui les relie par des tuyaux c'est ce
qu'on appelle la microfluidique ils vont
dire je vais carrément faire toute la
biologie d'un humain sur une puce ils
appellent ça à tort un humain sur puce
comme si finalement un humain ça n'était
que quelques cellules qui se cultive sur
un bout de plastique et qui sont reliés
par des tuyaux
cette vision réductionniste de ce qui
est humain est dramatique
il parle il commence à y avoir des
projets de dire on va faire des avatars
de chacun d'entre nous on aurait tous
notre petite puce avec notre biologie
qui est quelque part dans un frigo et
qui pourra être sorti pour étudier
quelles maladies on va voir où quel est
le meilleur médicament qu'on va faire si
on a six bouts ça ou si on est résistant
à sa allergiques et sait comment ça va
s'inscrire de quels usages on va faire
de cette puce certains vont beaucoup
plus loin ils disent la chose suivante
grâce aux nano on va pouvoir séquences
et tous les individus grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle on apprendra
très vite sur toute une population
qu'est-ce que codes ses gènes et grâce à
des technologies de
biotechnologie par exemple christophe
kass 9 on pourra réparer les gènes
défectueux
par exemple si je découvre quels sont
les gènes qui sont responsables du
vieillissement et que je trouve park et
soeurs 4,9 une façon de les remplacer et
que grâce à ces humains sur puce je
puisse ce très rapidement
criblé toutes les possibilités pour
arriver à quelque chose de fonctionnel
je vais très rapidement permettre aux
gens de devenir immortel c'est une grave
chose que de dire une chose pareille
s'est plaint de raccourcis scientifique
c'est du fantasme pur
il n'empêche que ces gens là sont des
scientifiques ils le disent ils sont
écoutés ils sont applaudis à ce qu'ils
font des conférences
il faut savoir garder raison
j'en arrive maintenant à cette dernière
partie de l'exploser pour vous dire que
ces technologies en les faisant petit
elle donne à homo sapiens une puissance
très importante
l'important maintenant c'est de savoir
quel usage on veut faire de cette
technologie pour quel futur
il y a déjà envoyé je les ai cités ici
vous les connaissez tous nick bostrom il
est philosophe tous les philosophes nous
dise pas ce qu'on vient d'entendre juste
avant jeff bezos ce vous connaissez
notre champion national laurent
alexandre ou raymond kurzweil qui
travaillent pour des gaffes et bien ces
personnes là sont riches et sont
puissantes elles disent la chose
suivante comme l'humain homo sapiens est
en train de polluer l'environnement qui
est autour de lui eh bien les conditions
de vie sur terre deviennent extrêmement
pénible exmor extrêmement difficile il
faut donc l'humain lui même par sa
technologie se change biologiquement
pour être capable de s'adapter à la
salissure qu'il provoque dans son micro
environnement et ils prônent cette thèse
qui sont des thèses transhumanistes ou
post humanistes qui sont qui doivent
être contredite qui sont des purs des
purs transgression et des purs fuite en
avant par nos technologies nous salit
son essai par noté l'aigle logique qu'il
faut nous mêmes nous modifier pour
survivre à nos propres salissures
évidemment face à eux
où est l'espoir l'espoir pour moi il est
par exemple d'ingres et attenberg qui
est le petit colibri dont on parlait
tout à l'heure qui arrive à dire moi
j'imagine un futur beaucoup plus
responsable beaucoup plus soutenable
pour reprendre les propos de loin que
alexandre notre champion de france du
transhumanisme il a dit récemment dans
une chronique dans l'express que
finalement dans la bataille entre jeff
des os et greta tandberg
eh bien il donnait pas cher de la peau
de grayson vert il a tort tous ces
postes humanistes tous étrange humaniste
qui nous disent c'est inéluctable que
l'homo sapiens aille vers plus de
salissures et doit se transformer et
bien c'est inéluctabilité elle n'est pas
vrai rien n'est inéluctable
les petit colibri ont le droit de
s'exprimer et je vous invite tous avec
moi a essayé de penser à un futur où on
pourrait utiliser les nouvelles
technologies pour un futur soutenable et
durable
c'est ce qui va conclure cet exposé
je voudrais le traduire par un grand
appel on pourra appeler ça l'appel de
l'unsa de même 2019 moi je veux bien me
transformé par les technologies chiche
je vous propose de nous transformer mais
je voudrais que 1 essayant de comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui l'intelligence de nos
systèmes n'est pas forcément dans la
science qui a derrière ni dans la
complexité technologique de ces
dispositifs
tel qu'on le croit aujourd'hui
l'intelligence de ce que nous fabriquons
de nos artefacts elle se trouve aussi
dans la justesse de ce que nous
fabriquons à la place qu'ils vont
occuper dans le monde et je pense qu'il
est temps pour nous de penser que tous
ensemble on peut construire un futur des
scénarios dans lequel homo sapiens qui
est devenu homo faber redeviennent
sapiens et mon cri ce soir c'est celui
là c'est mon engagement et vous êtes
tous conviés futurs ingénieurs futurs
chercheurs futur philosophe futurs
économistes à réfléchir à ça avec vous
avec moi j'aimerais que nounours à pied
nizon attention c'est pas facile à dire
mon cri ce soir c'est ressas pied nizon
nous re s'appuyer nizon nous et je vous
invite à le dire avec mon attention je
me suis entraîné souvent pour pas
bégayer allez-y re ca pérennisant nous
merci c'est fantastique
bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]